[Music]
[Applause]
everybody welcome to awesome comics your
one-stop shop for everything count book
entertainment I'm your host Walter
Brennan yak and today we are talking
about the top 10 episodes of Batman
Beyond I'm really hyped to do this this
is what my favorite shows from the DCAU
and we have some great people to talk
about it and introduce them right after
I talk about this the Facebook page
facebook.com slash awesome comic show
new videos every single Thursday I give
us a like on there we're approaching
2000 as the recording of this so uh give
us more likes people to give you some
special later ok so intros let's get
into this really quick mr. Brian Porter
how's it going buddy so you ready to
talk about Bambi on youth all right cool
miss Heather Roose how's it going it's
going well had a lot of episodes to
watch but you know that's what days off
school or for example iron wait how's it
going good I'm basically ready to talk
Bevin an all-time great time I love
Batman Beyond I was talking I was
telling Walter earlier today I had like
the little plastic like tableware set
like it is and like there were a
see-through cuts stem you can see Terry
McGinnis and fit yeah and I still have
those at my dad's house that's awesome
this that's fantastic
I want to say before we get really into
this that uh because know we're gonna
get a lot of comments about this so the
return of the Joker movie then and
Beyond return the Joker we that we're
not gonna cover that because that is a
movie ok that was a home release that is
not an episode of the show also the
episode of Justice League Unlimited
called epilogue is a very Batman Beyond
centric show a lot of big stuff happened
in that maybe we'll talk about that at a
later date but that is not an episode at
bat and beyond so we're not to be
talking about that so let's get in to
the top Tampa throws a baton behind with
number 10
where's Terry season two
okay where's Terry it's good episode
it's very good episode it's he gets
trapped in a collapsed subway right yeah
Tunnel here yeah that's a cool setting
for the story yeah and then he's stuck
with this kid who's kind of a little
little twerk - yeah man
DAC short for daiquiri right play like
the morality to that we get to see how
moral Terry is as a person
yeah like when they're when he like
right in the beginning of the episode
when they get trapped him in the kid and
he can't fit through the like hole he's
made in the ceiling and he's like okay
well better one of us get out the
neither of us right it's like what no
nuts and then later the kid as a choice
of you know being the better person of
like should he save him or not like it's
not up to him he's not a superhero right
Batman kind of inspires him is a
skeptical little kid also we get to see
Bruce in action in this old man Bruce
team up with Maxine which is a great
team up I would have liked to see more
of those two together Bruce also
basically saves the day at the end of
this episode knocks out shrieking just
like whatever bro it looks away it's
pretty awesome so yeah this is a good
episode not the best but it is in the
top ten I me and Ayanna both put us on
our top ten so go ahead and check out
where's teri if you get a chance okay
number nine number nine was a blackout
from season one this is the first time
that I mean Terry basically fights a
villain it's like episode three right
yeah a very early this is ynx
introduction yes it's the introduction
to ink it has some cool battle scenes
with the way that ink manipulates a
couple of cool shots is running away
from her where do you think of ink is a
villain in the series oh I like ink a
lot I mean I had initially on my list
put blackout slash disappearing ink one
another so that she's in cuz I also
really enjoy disappearing ink as well
but she's a great villain very
interesting especially with the idea
that like her DNA is kind of degrading
and then once they do freeze her at the
end of the episode I mean spoilers I
guess I don't know when they get her
frozen at the end of the episode then
she comes back at disappearing ink and
like her DNA has degraded to the point
where she can
even become a human exam it's very
interesting you see she has a daughter
another episode right there like one of
her last episodes I think as we see her
daughter and but I like how she's able
to like manipulate people it's very
interesting in Finland yeah and she kind
of gets her comeback with her dad air
hole disappeared anchors like the
lovestruck car in her room
yes yeah yeah it was really good
okay.thank is a really unique villain I
think that after blackout and besides
disappearing she pops up in the show a
lot yeah I'd be a little bit overexposed
and she isn't really as special as she
was in these first couple episodes and
in the last one but yeah blackout is
definitely a top-10 episode they get to
use mrs. freeze gun at the end like yes
yeah we get to see a lot of cool stuff
the penny gets like shoved at them in
the Batcave so we get to see Bruce once
again sort of help out Terry which is
really cool and kind of partially relive
his past a little bit right yeah I guess
you all this stuff I just love him
putting on the Gray Ghost then yeah it's
a family moment for me okay speaking of
mr. Freeze's gun let's go to number
eight number eight meltdown from season
one okay so meltdown is a very famous
mr. freeze episode from this so
basically mr. freeze is still alive yeah
but he's just a disembodied head or I
know he's like three via I mean even his
introduction he's basically saying like
I wish I could die yeah it's a great
story I mean for us to freeze it's
another tragedy for him I mean because
he's such a tragic character to begin
with and we get to see him he's almost
gets redeemed he's so close and you can
see he so sincerely wants to be redeemed
like the character is a very strong
sympathetic character and when you see
him come back he's got a new lease on
life he's got a new body he's really
trying to you know help people out and
he says he's sorry to the guy who he
killed his family and everything and in
that graveyard scene I mean it's it's a
character that the more you think about
the more it's like I really wish it
would have worked out for him but it you
know ed mr. freeze is that it character
yes right yeah a depth of character and
- yeah one of my favorites and one of
the most memorable episodes of this
right I mean it really struck a chord
with me yeah I'll have to do freeze - by
the way yeah the new free suit is bad
doesn't
the gun anymore just like wrist cannons
and everything right right and I love
that like as he busted the floor yeah it
was he busted the floor and that's
another I spun moment I kept it in cold
storage I kept in close talk about this
before I will just say it every episode
love a good I spun yes of course
let me get to see blight this is the
first time Terry sees blight so I didn't
get to see blight versus Mr Freeze which
is really cool a little fight we get to
see which is awesome and I love the the
dynamic between Terry and Bruce and this
Bruce does not trust Mr Freeze he's been
through it I mean he knows that he's
kind of a good guy inside but he knows
he just can't trust him or Terry is the
first time he's seeing him he really
wants to trust him but things are
tragically doesn't work out as well so
at the end they have a little
conversation it's really nice so yeah
great episode great character episode
for mr. freeze he doesn't pop up again
but this was a great episode to go on
for him okay so moving on to number
seven number seven we've got the egg
baby from season two I believe yes yes
okay there's a fantastic ridiculous
episode this actually won an Emmy oh
yeah and it came out around the time of
return of the Joker and you so this was
about that time frame - um I listened to
the commentary actually on the DVDs and
it was really annoyed how much um first
Tim kept saying it was like such a girl
friendly episode Oh like Kevin I was
like why why is that cousin baby there's
egg babies and there was another like a
home at class or whatever yeah yeah and
then there's like a close-up of
someone's screen this is really so she's
like boo boring yeah but he has to like
take care of this egg but also still be
Batman and I just love the idea of
having to like deal with both of those
like something realistic and then also
superhero it up a little bit right
Batman beyond holding an egg a little
head like a baby is fantastic and I yeah
going - I'm gonna go beat these people
up and like oh the baby's kind of
up all off the building or whatever I
gotta go save the baby yeah particular
funny someone that's like a teenager
someone that's still going through
school like Buffy where you're like
you're trying to like do this whole
social thing and school thing but also
you have this commitment to save the
world like how are you able to juggle
all those and this was one of those
really good episode more lighthearted
episode there's a lot more moments in
this but yeah it's a good stuff so they
don't work anymore so go check it out
guys
okay moving on to number six number six
I witness season two okay I witness is a
really good episode because we get to
see this sort of coming to a head of
Barbara Gordon who is the Commissioner
now of the Gotham police department and
Terry who she doesn't really trust and
this is also kind of getting back at
Bruce because they've had a rocky
relationship in this story well first
kind of has to decide who he trusts more
basically um like does he believe
Barbara Gordon who wouldn't lie but also
there's Terry who he hasn't completely
sussed out yet really but doesn't
believe could like go so far as to kill
someone so exact very interesting to see
the the battlefront this was actually
their first Bruce Timm was talking about
in the commentary this was their first
computer edited a special episode
episode yeah you can definitely tell the
difference from because it's still kind
of like the old Batman animated series
type it's still streamlined the
animation style but it's actually he's
sort of like you know you see the the
blips on the screen and stuff and with
the digital episodes it's much cleaner
film idea pretty good villain is raising
right good new villain yeah Bambi
ongoing he I don't like there's some
other more interesting episodes I think
of him as a villain I don't think this
is a very strong like Spellbinder
episode or say but I like him I think he
he's really frustrating because you can
do whatever you want and do whatever
right right well this a very memorable
episode in general because I even
remember this episode watching it as a
child and just like when you see
Spellbinders illusion of Terry killing
him it's like oh my gosh Terry just oh
my gosh yeah very memorable yeah
definitely um so yeah Barbara Gordon
versus Batman once this once again yeah
that's a good episode okay moving on to
number five
number-5 splicers season 2
all right this is a deadly night my
lasso I like you were saying I remember
this for my first watch okay it gave me
nightmares when I was a child I do ever
before that I represent yeah it's a
really good episode I really liked it
yeah
like combining the know the animal being
the way I look and like it potentially
taking over and how progressive they are
in the terms of the body modifications
in right that time frame it's like yeah
that was when it was body mods word but
like getting getting to be big and like
popular things so this episode was kind
of like corresponding to that being in
the poke culture I'm glad they got to
use ace in this episode yeah we thought
about it cool very cool this is a badass
right and yeah yeah they don't touch my
dog from him finding the giant snake
bird yeah yeah thing that turned into a
view that's great and then he turned
into whatever that abomination
combination yeah that was another ending
that almost shocked me the way that
Terry defeated him is just basically
overdosed him you know just took all the
rest of the whatever it was yeah and
just some good music too there is good
music yeah I think there's always good
in music this series I think this
episode specifically has just a really
good score going on I liked this one
yeah enough to like note it more than
others so I got you all right well let's
move on to number four
number four the call part 22 from season
three good good Superman Beyond that's
all you really got to say we get it
black and white
vo it's a cool suit but it is weird it's
a lot of the gray yeah yeah there's a
little gray on the side very cool mr.
fantastic right you bring in Superman
into this into this situation you get to
see him react to Bruce and them interact
again and they get to see him talk to
the new Batman and Terry and everything
did very very cool interactions you get
to see a new Justice League
yeah introduction of Warhawk in this
episode I really like The Last Airbender
Green Lantern oh my god I didn't know
watch my answer but yeah this is a
two-parter I think I mean this is pretty
even in terms of which episodes better
technically maybe the first episode good
ending is great because you guys seem
like the last remnant of a piece of
kryptonite that Bruce is kept for all
these years
yeah like all the cobwebs that are on
the side of the wall when he splits the
suits apart and that's where the
Kryptonite is yeah it's really cool and
I just really like for the whole thing
with Warhawk
suit and then the helmet oh great vision
yeah yeah that looks awesome
that was really good and it was pretty
proud of like holy he's dead yeah I
know and then I've sowed two of this
part two we get to see that Superman has
been taken over by Starro years they
celebrate for you know why all right
time
I love the the moment maybe that's my
favorite in this is when Batman is going
away in the the Batmobile and Superman's
like behind him but he's like not flying
regularly he's like lean this way
because star owes on him and they played
the Superman theme from the animated
series the other day does it dad but
it's distorted it's like
and it's all just like creates a really
cool moment that that's not really
Superman but he's got all cigarettes
powers yeah a really really cool visual
there so yeah it's also kind of a
prototype episode for Justice League get
see little team up at the end there
that's pretty cool alright well that was
number four let's go number three number
three dead man's hand from season one
alright that's a really cool episode I
like seeing the yoga okay yeah I like
seeing the Royal Flush gang is really
awesome it like the Royal Flush I
control I understand if someone's like
annoyed by them but I like them right
like the whole idea of a family of
criminals rioting powers for generation
to generation marrying people in based
on like if they're criminals like I love
it yeah that's good stuff I mean I think
the main reason why y'all like this
episode is Melanie ten yeah Jerry's
relationship yeah yeah that's a really
cool little twist on cuz we see that
Terry's with Dana like the entire series
right right so it's cool to see like a
little break in the status quo from that
and it's believable because Terry is
very much like an outsider kind of guy
he's very much kind of like a loner so
we get to see him interact with another
loner it's basically like the Catwoman
Batman dynamic from Bruce's era so and
they even mention that in the show which
is really cool right right about Selina
Kyle yeah let me tell you about a woman
named Selina Kyle there's some really
good action sequences and yeah oh yeah
yeah there's like some nice tension
between Bruce and Terry in this where
they're kind of butting heads about
about how he should still be going out
as Batman but he wants kind of normal
teenage life yes I go out once in a
while and he said what's the one night
you know that's not gonna make a
difference and he grabs and Bruce grabs
and says what one might always makes a
difference right yeah it's great line
from Bruce you could see how committed
he still is to this so yeah I loved that
moment and this is a great episode okay
moving on to number two
number two rebirth season one parts one
and two these are the first two episodes
of bat and beyond
honestly they come out kick in yo the
opening opening scene is incredible yeah
I don't know if it's ever quite reach
that peak of that first like three
minutes it's great this was my number
one pick overall for the entire series I
freaking loved the first two episodes
really quick Batman fighting and then he
has that heart attack he almost uses the
gunner I shocked by even having the gun
not even he didn't even use it he just
threatened to use it yeah he was still
so shocked by it and never again yeah
hey it shows how much Batman hates guns
Neider what are you talking about yeah
good talk is your part
nah I'm cool well yeah it's just really
awesome it had set a really good tone oh
absolutely
I really this great episode going into
the the end of the first episode will
reseed Terry's father dies this is the
soul missile origin stories very cool he
doesn't like his father he's like a
rebellious teenager and that disease
thing that creates blight from Derek
powers is very interesting Tim and
little scary yeah I mean they show this
is our first experiment with livestock
and then it yeah and it but it doesn't
show you here though yeah that's that's
that's how you scare people yeah let
their imagination do the work cuz you
show them a little bit and you're like
okay this happens what happened to the
man day one two hours after that and
then after that and then you don't show
them the cards like what could it be
those are so bad right so this is one of
those episodes I really let your
imagination land with you absolutely god
you're gonna be right and I like the
conflict even the in the very beginning
with Terry and Bruce like we're Bert
when he retains Massoud like this
freezes them and lets them take that
beating I'm like oh stop he's gonna die
right right yeah so uh yeah this is a
great two-parter it's very close to
being the best of the series so I think
you need to go and watch these two if
anything out of it a two-parter I think
you'll enjoy this because it connects
back to the original series as well
so go ahead and check that out we could
see Bruce or Terry's first night as
Batman as well so there's only one
episode that's better in this let's go
to number one number one out of the past
from season three episode opens with
Batman the musical that was i
relaunching it I did not remember Batman
the musical basically like at all and I
was doing other things I was sewing I
was doing something and I heard it and I
was like okay I got stuff and said hey
watch this like 10 times this is amazing
oh good right well it's great because it
brings back a whole bunch of the things
from the in minute series or other
Batman lord um you know they Talia comes
back or yes so we think it's Talia I
liked that it was going to be Talia and
then it was great rope creaking and she
kissed Bruce actually yeah yeah it's
like mama steady coos yeah yeah freaking
me out that way right yeah you creep
tipping you out she kiss me yeah and I
just like the conflict of Bruce like
finally like you know what I'm gonna do
it then yeah kind of giving into what he
wants right no internal as earth right
Lazarus and we began Italian I think
this could have been a really cool arc
for like half a season that's true you
could have seen a young Bruce that
slowly is getting older but you get to
see him sort of team up with with
Terry's Batman for like I just could
like even like five to six episodes of
like a cool little arc but it just
self-contained everything I agree that I
would have enjoyed a like a little short
yeah I really did like that they kept
achar self-contained still cool still
cool but it still could have been a
really interesting dynamic between those
it also says a lot for each they
sacrifice a daughter II years ago yeah
right and that just gave him really not
too much pause like right a little bit
of it but he just aren't I'm gone and
even the way he puts it like Talia made
the ultimate sacrifice for you man not
like I killed her she did like she made
the ultimate second we agree maybe
the best film of the whole series one of
if not is is when Bruce and Terry team
up and they fight off like the goons at
races place and they played the the BAM
anime series theme in the Bambi on
guitar that's like one of the best like
ten seconds yes in like animation
history episode has this little like say
like animated series fangirl moment
really just like a little tip of the hat
here alright a little jibba the hey even
in the beginning when Bruce is looking
through the pictures of like his old
flames there's like Selena show moments
which is cool yeah yeah so that's our
number one episode guys that those are
our top ten episodes of Batman Beyond
it's a great show one of the best the
DCAU has had to offer one of the best DC
shows period I think is Bambi on it
continued the story of Anna in the
animated series in a whole different way
you never would even thought of we get
to see Bruce as an old man which is he's
my favorite character in this animal Ben
Bruce the old man Bruce is amazing and I
love him and I love his interaction with
Terry and the fact that Terry is so so
far different from Bruce is just a
really cool back-and-forth that you get
to see them go through and everything
and they're the heart of the show
obviously as Bruce and Terry and then
the other villains they created like
blight and Spellbinder and ink and other
characters in the show like the return
mr. freeze is also very cool obviously
so this is a really strong show any
closing statements for you guys really
quick I really like the Batman Beyond
suit like it's one of my favorite yeah
like costume suits whatever in the
entirety of the DC Universe I really
looks awesome yeah it still looks great
very badass
that's delete your ristic yeah like the
low like jetpack issues yeah and then
just the way that the wings come out
it's very angular and like just I love
the angles on it just the mouth is a
really cool idea that that yeah there's
like no mouth there's no mouth cut in
the eyes it just looks so good yeah it's
just a fantastic suit our guzik's of the
show is it's so it's so far removed from
the animated series and there are crest
real stuff but it's got something yeah
it really does even that like opening
theme song and stuff and hold on get you
pumped up right if you're marathoning it
I recommend skipping the credits because
then you hear like it back-to-back and
you're like okay you
enough for the intro but I don't need
the credit stick um but man yeah that's
a that's a great thing huh
and in general it's held up really well
like I enjoyed rewatching this yeah I
mean there's a couple of super like
early like late 90s ish Nissa bout it
but it's not it's not bad like it's
great yeah it has stood the test of time
I agree well I agree oh my gosh I like
mixing this Soulja of the 90s with the
idea of the future okay so we're going
to find guys in social media really
quickly
Heather um you can find me on Twitter at
Heather ruse or Instagram at H ruse all
right Porter facebook.com slash awesome
Porter and I think I'm pretty sure my
twitter handle is pork chop Oh 2 8 9
they're found porter on twitter on the
show i have a twitter i don't really use
it much but i might now if you follow me
a shout out to you freak you're awesome
that's great Wow Twitter followers shout
out I can't there's a lot of you I'm
sorry but I'm on Twitter you can find me
there and a lot of you already follow me
there I'm also on snapchat uh and
Facebook Facebook Diana wait it's very
easy to find um and a shout out to
legion of collectors from a sweet swag
thank you so much for they sent me hey
Batman villains box yeah yeah funk up
you go awesome blog as sweet sweet hat
don't look at my hat hair um and a
couple of pop vinyls that I collect so
thank you very much appreciate it great
stuff and you can follow me on twitter
at awesome underscore Walter as well
talking about all things comic book
related rocky related 40th anniversary
guys gonna watch rocky but you do
yourself a favor folks go watch the
Rocky movies you'll feel good about
yourself top top 5 and watch top 5 and
if you're watching it your parent you're
watching it anyway so we gotta tell you
about that yeah go ahead watch top 5 as
well so - like this video yes like this
video if you if you like Batman the
Animated Series you should give us a
like yes let us know what your favorite
yeah what are your favorite episodes of
and beyond what do you think the show
hold up let us know in the comments
below
um so until next week I'm Walter burn a
dziak these guys as usual
are the best the best people ever and
we'll see you on the next page
[Music]
[Applause]
you